[Music]
the mystery genre is long been a
mainstay in anime when it might not be
one of the most mainstream genres around
it comes with no shortage of moments to
keep the fans anticipating admits all
the mysteries and suspenseful moments
often lies a chance for us to take a
more introspective look at not just
ourselves but humanity as a whole today
we'll be discussing a top 10 list of
mystery thriller anime so sit back relax
and watch as we go through some of
animates finest offerings in the genre
do take care though
because a lot of these shows can mess
with your mind in more ways than one
[Music]
at number 10 we have Madoka Magica this
is a magical anime starring Madoka a
regular middle school girl whose life
gets changed upon a chance encounter
with a white cat-like creature called
cube a the creature offers the school
girls a chance to become magical girls
in order to fight witches all they have
to do though is to make a wish however
it seems there's more to cube a in the
world of magical girls than it seems
Madoka Magica as legacy can still be
felt years after finished well I
wouldn't call it the first dark magical
girl anime it seems to be the series
that turn the conventions of succeeding
magical girl shows upside down Madoka
Magica isn't just a magical girl anime
with a dark twist the series is so
methodical and detailed in terms of
character growth symbolism and even the
things that they put in the background
down to the finest detail one starts off
as a cute magical girl show quickly
turns into an artistic tale of hope and
despair ninth on the list is Terra in
resonance in terror in resonance Tokyo
finds itself a victim of a shocking
terrorist attack the culprits two
teenagers who call themselves Sphinx the
duo launch a series of terrorist attacks
accompanied by a riddle while the world
continues to be baffled at finding out
the identity of the culprits kenjiro
shibasaki of the police division
succeeds in solving the riddles and
begins engaging the duo in a battle of
minds look actual terrorist protagonists
in all seriousness having such
protagonists opens up several mysteries
such as questions as to why our main
characters ended up becoming extremists
the story behind the two is actually a
lot more tragic than you'd expect
adding to that are moral questions and
some political parallels and the good ol
saying that everything is political
can't be any truer for terror in
resonance and on with amazing music and
animation the show is also filled with
thrilling action that leaves you wanting
more
coming up next at number eight its
garden of sinners now for something
different God loves sinners is a series
of movie starring shecky due to her
upbringing she lives in isolation and so
she encounters ordinary high school
student Mickey ax murders begin
occurring in the city with Shiki
becoming a prime suspect
Mickey o refuses to believe that the
girl he befriended is responsible for
everything despite seeing her on the
site of one such gruesome killing garden
of sinners has this nifty thing where
the story isn't told in order yes they
put a Haruhi on us only a lot more
serious and edgy bewitching ly
captivating and with its unrestrained
violence boldness to tackle mature
issues and an ever-present
air of mystery garden of sinners will be
a draining experience that isn't for the
unprepared but past all of that is one
of the more amazing works in the world
of anime
[Music]
number seven is paranoia agent in
paranoia agent the police are on the
trail of a legendary figure called Shona
bat appearing is a team that wield two
bent baseball bat he sets off to attack
the people in Musashino furthermore his
attacks don't seem random at all as he
only attacks those who fit a certain
category if you're not aware the creator
of this anime is the leisa Toshi khan
known for his mind-bending style that's
putting it kindly in directing visuals
if you come in looking for something
easy to watch you might end up
disappointed here much like its central
character paranoia agents not to show
that can be easily digested and consumed
at the end of it all
paranoia agent showcases what made
Satoshi Kon one of the most renowned
personalities in anime surreal
fear-inducing visuals a helpful dose of
social commentary and a mystery full of
twists with a great ending of what
awaits those who watch this series
[Music]
our number six mystery thriller anime is
none other than death parade death
parades premise is simple after death
two people enter a bar named kwinda kim
with no memories of how they got there
enter the white head bartender de kim
who crosses the pan to play a game with
their lives on the line as the game
progresses more and more gets revealed
about the characters and we begin to see
that when it comes to people there's
really more than meets the eye
death parades interesting in its take of
life after death
the Japanese afterlife has been a
subject of interest for quite a while
now with its various reimagine ations
to have it imagined as a bar where
people play death games is very creative
and definitely a refreshing take on it
death parade excels in how it
essentially provides numerous character
studies at the end of the day death
parade certainly teaches us not to judge
a book by its cover or a person by his
appearance whichever applies
[Music]
coming in at number five is steins gate
Rintaro Okabe claims to be a mad
scientist in reality he's just an
eccentric socially inept university
student after discovering time-travel
under strange circumstances he and his
colleagues must use their knowledge of
it to stop an evil organization in their
diabolical plans steins gate takes a
concept that we've grown accustomed to
time travel and masterfully applies its
own take on it
while most series take the concept of
time travel and use it merely as a plot
point steins gate goes the next mile
while a car bait deals with tough
choices we get to join the action
grappling with the concepts that the
show presents us theorizing on the fate
of the characters and waiting for the
next major development steins gate has
the magical ability to keep its viewers
completely engaged with every step
making this series the ultimate show to
pick up if you want a mystery anime that
deals with time-travel at number four we
have when they cry a show with cute
girls tagged under mystery thriller then
the girls are chilling and hanging out
in a quiet town setting my hand after
Madoka what could go wrong the second
time around when they cry may seem
unspectacular at first it's the tried
and true visual novel of the main
character ket moving to a province where
he befriends new classmates that look as
if they can conveniently form a harem
the seeming peace and quiet abruptly
ends after he learns about a murder that
happens every few years surely none of
these cute girls that he just prefer
ended can be the ones responsible right
right this anime is unique since its
timelines keep getting reset some people
might think that they're watching some
kind of erased or re0 prototype with a
time-travel shenanigans
overall this animes main selling point
comes from urging the viewers to know
more about the characters you get pulled
into the mystery of how the seemingly
sweetest characters can commit such
heinous acts
[Music]
number three on the list is something
that you should be quite familiar with
the promised Neverland
the promised neverland's a recent series
about the orphanage grace field house
the kids live happily is one big family
under the care of Isabella the mom of
the orphanage after finding out the
truth about the orphanage two of the
smartest kids in there Emma and Norman
begin to lay down the plans from mass
exodus the premise may sound simple
enough but the promised Neverland is as
thrilling as it gets the game of wits is
something to look out for and a lot of
character development unfolds as the
series progresses while the anime
adaption does have its shortcomings its
production especially when it comes to
setting the tone and atmosphere more
than make up for it the promised
Neverland is one hell of a suspenseful
ride keeping viewers on the edge of
their seats as they find out whether the
children can escape the chains of fate
is it any surprise that we have Death
Note at number two in this list Death
Note tells the story of Light Yagami his
life changes when he stumbles upon the
Death Note a notebook with the ability
to kill any person whose name's written
in it recognizing the power that's
fallen into its hands light begins
request of purging the world of
criminals things aren't that easy though
as the police turn their attention to
apprehending the mysterious serial
killer of criminals
enlisting the help of the genius
detective el the game of cat-and-mouse
begins Death Note tries to answer a
whole lot of questions about morals
ethics and justice do criminals really
deserve a second chance
is the world's judicial system flawed
should anyone have the right to take the
lives of other people's into their own
hands for its success death no also
inspired a lot of spin-offs side stories
and even musicals that doesn't even
include the seemingly endless
live-action adaptations and retellings
both great and those that are rather
unflattering
[Music]
finally we have monster taking the
number one spot in a list of top mystery
thriller anime what a way to cap off the
list with the critically acclaimed
masterpiece of now Kiara Sawa monster
tells the story of dr. Kenzo Tenma
a young surgeon disappointed at the
politics and bias within his hospital he
decides to ignore subsequent orders and
operate on a young boy named Johan
Libert saving his life years later to
his surprise he encounters Johann once
more this time as a murderer being
referred to as a monster seeking to fix
his mistake of creating this monster dr.
Tenma goes after Johann when it comes to
mystery thrillers monsters by far one of
the best in terms of setting the tone
and atmosphere for the type of story
that is trying to tell it's without much
of the supernatural elements and
archetypal characters that anime often
takes pride in and it instead works as
an amazing well grounded look at the
human psyche filled to the brim with
suspense deep characters and an
intricate plot that would provoke you
into thinking about life monsters surely
a must watch
well that's it for this video I hope you
can find a show that you really like
among the ones on this list today if
you'd like to recommend some other shows
in the missionary thriller genre then
feel free to do so in the comment
section below don't forget to hit that
like button if you enjoyed the video and
subscribe if you haven't already I'll
see you next time on village you
[Music]